hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of our readers Liz who's just
starting the business with a partner and
wrote in and wanted to know what are the
important things that need to be
considered to have a really good start
so Liz Congrats instead of the new
business I hope you do really well some
quick advice for you the first thing I
would do and I've said that a lot of
these videos is build around the
customer so go find somebody who needs
your services before you start spending
anything before you start building up
your platform find customers who have a
problem that you can help solve that
problem for them they're willing to pay
you for you have money coming in the
door which always helps and you're
building around the customer who can
give you feedback on what to do next or
where to grow your business so start
talking to customers and find that
customer I was willing to pay you as you
launch your business the second thing is
don't spend money until you're making
money right it's easy to spend money
anybody can spend money you know it's
not difficult to go out and buy
expensive business cards and market
material in an office and a company car
and spend spend spend right it's easy to
go and spend don't start spending until
you're making money especially if you're
in consulting or service type of
business try to put in as much sweat
equity as possible so that you're
preserving your money right that can be
your lifeline see how long you can last
in the business so you want to make sure
you're making a lot of money before you
start spending it the third thing I
would do is try to follow your passion
may choose to accept it but what you're
doing make sure you bring something new
to the industry that hasn't been done
before and then you cannot a lot of
extra great value to your customers
because you're really excited about what
and you're really passionate and
knowledgeable about your field so don't
do something just to make money do
something because you're really
passionate about it I know you can make
a difference that is a really big
differentiating factor between
entrepreneurs who are super successful
and the ones who aren't because they
really love what they're doing are
really passionate about it
so I hope that helped Liz if you guys
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below and I'd love to hear your
thoughts and feedback you can leave a
comment and stay tuned for the next
episode
you